Good morning, John, this is what I'm planning
on wearing to your movie premiere. I don't
know, is it too much? Is it not enough? I
don't know. Coming all the way from Montana,
show those New York people a thing or two
about how people should dress: you know, with
a dead cow on them. Check out the tie: TFiOS
colors tie.
John, we have officially received over 100,000
responses to the 2014 Nerdfighteria Census.
Which is even more exciting because over half
of the 140,000 that responded last year didn't
respond this year. I don't know what those
people were doing; there's 100,000 of them.
Maybe they figured they'd do one census, but
I should wait four years or so before I do
another one, right? But, it's not because
people weren't around last year because 75%
of respondents have been watching since before
2013. That's a lot of long-time nerdfighters.
Other interesting data from the survey, 100%
of people say my new album Incongruent is
a masterful work of genius. It was the only
option I gave them, but still. Actually, a
lot of people didn't even know that I have
a new album, so, I have a new album! In fact,
there are a number of things we do that people
didn't know anything about.
14% of people don't know about the Mental
Floss channel where we're constantly spewing
interesting facts about the world.
30% of people don't know that we've spun off
SciShow into a second SciShow channel, so
there's SciShow and SciShow Space.
33% of people don't know about our year-old
YouTube sex education and information show
Sexplanations with Dr. Lindsey Doe.
50% of people don't know about How To Adult,
our guide to suddenly becoming an adult and
OH GOD OH GOD!
64% of people don't know about our new show
Animal Wonders, but the number one most underground,
super-indie, nobody knows about it thing that's
part of all of our enterprises is The Warehouse.
The Warehouse is a show that is produced out
of the DFTBA Records warehouse by Matthew
Gaydos, who is the head of Customer Service
at DFTBA Records. I actually watched him do
a show at Sean Kelly's last night in Missoula.
He is a rock star.
Somewhat difficult for me to believe is that
40% of people don't know about Subbable. I
just feel like everybody knows about it because
it has been so successful for helping us fund
our shows, like, SciShow and CrashCourse and
Sexplanations would all not exist any more
if it weren't for Subbable.
For those 40%of people who don't know, Subbable
is our voluntary subscription platform. You
can go and subscribe to any of a number of
projects, and when you subscribe you can choose
an amount to pay per month. And that can be
0 dollars, it could be 5 or 10, or a million
dollars a month. Nobody's done that yet. And
that helps those shows exist for everybody,
including people who can't pay for them.
Speaking of people who can't pay for them
-- in the comments of the questions about
Subbable and DFTBA and my album, there are
lots of people saying "I just don't have money,
I feel really bad that I haven't bought your
things, but I don't have money..." Don't feel
bad. About that ever! That is the last thing
I want, is for you to spend money when it
will make you less financially secure.
If you buy something from us and it's making
you less financially secure, I am not happy.
Don't do that. No.
And really astonishingly, 1) More people have
read J. K. Rowling books than have read John
Green books, but only very slightly. And something
like 92% of you have read The Fault in Our
Stars, which is a lot.
So I'm assuming that all of those people will
be interested in going to The Night Before
Our Stars. It's an event that's happening
all over America, not outside America, sorry
not-America people. Also not in everywhere
in America. Like it's not happening here in
Missoula for example.
It's the screening of the movie, the day before
it comes out, on June 5th. 5:30 Eastern, 8:30
Pacific, I think. And then after the movie,
there's going to be a livestream of questions
and interviews and music, with John Green:
my brother, the guy on the other side of this
camera. Nat Wolff, Ansel Elgort, Shailene
Woodley, Josh Boone: the director, other people.
It's gonna be cool. You should check it out,
if you can. Sorry, very sorry, to all the
people who can't.
John, congratulations. Coming to your premiere!
Gonna get on a plane tomorrow and come see
you! Looking forward to it. I'll see you then.
LeVar Burton: Though I have to say, Hank,
your video about how to field strip a fusion
reactor or realign the power transfer tunnel
in a warp coil generator is lacking in the
most rudimentary understanding of matter-antimatter
principles.